PROFESSOR: PageRank is a measure
of the importance of a web
page.
But let me immediately
correct my own confusion
that I suffered
from for some time
until very recently, which
is that even though PageRank
is used for ranking pages,
it's called PageRank
after its discoverer,
developer, Larry Page,
was one of the co-founders
along with Serg Brin of Google.
So the motivation is that when
you-- at least before Google,
when you did a standard
retrieval on a web page
using keyword Search and
similar kinds of criteria,
you'd get back millions
of hits, most of which
were really low
quality and you weren't
interested in, and with
a few useful pages buried
in the millions.
And the question was,
all of these documents
are indistinguishable in terms
of keyword search and textual
patterns, how do you figure out
which are the important ones.
And the idea that
Page came up with
was to use the web
structure itself,
the structure of
the worldwide web,
to identify the
important documents.
So we can think of the
whole internet as a graph
where a user is on a page, and
we think of a URL as a link
to another page,
as a directed edge.
And users are kind of
randomly traveling around
in the worldwide web.
They're at a page, they
randomly click a link
to get to another
page, and they keep
doing a walk on the web graph.
And every once in
a while, they're
going to find that the
thread that they're on
is kind of losing steam,
where they find themselves
in some kind of a cycle and they
will randomly start over again
at some other page.
And we want to
argue or hypothesize
that a page is
more important when
it's viewed a large
fraction of the time
by these random browsers
and random users.
So to be formal,
we're going to take
the entire worldwide web,
trillions of vertices,
as a digraph.
And there's going to be an
edge from one URL to another,
from V to W, if there's a link
from the page V to the page W,
or the URL W. W might
not even be a page,
it might be a document,
which means it
doesn't have any links on it.
But for the real vertices
are the web pages
that have links on them.
OK, that's the model.
And we're going to make it
into a random walk graph
by saying that if you look
at a URL V, at a vertex V,
all of the edges out of
it are equally likely.
It's a simple model, and
it might or might not work.
But in fact, it did
work pretty well.
That is the model of the
worldwide web as a random walk
graph.
So to be more precise,
the probability
of the edge that
goes from V to W
is 1 over the out
degree of V. That
is, all of the out
degree of V edges
leaving vertex V
get equal weight.
Now to model this aspect
that the users start over
again if they get bored
or they get stuck,
we can formally
add to the digraph
a hypothetical super-node,
which-- and with the property
that there's an edge from the
super-node to every other node
with equally likelihood.
So once you hit
the super-node then
following an edge is tantamount
to saying, pick a random page
and start over again.
To get to the
super-node, we have
edges back from other
nodes in the graph
back to the super-node.
In the reading, we
said that we were
going to have nodes back
from terminal nodes that
had no edges out.
For example, a document
or something like that.
That's actually not sufficient,
because-- for the PageRank
to work in the theoretical
way that we want it
to because even if
there is no dead nodes,
you might be in a clump of nodes
which you can't get out of.
And you'd want to be able to--
and even though none of them
was a dead end, because they
all had arrows going out
to each other.
And so you'd really want
a node from a-- an edge
from a clump like that
back to the super-node
to model starting over there.
The simplest way
to do it really is
to simply say that there's
an edge to the super-node
from every vertex.
So wherever you are, you can
randomly decide to start over.
And Page and Brin
and their co-authors
in the original
paper on PageRank
suggested that the
edge back from a vertex
to the super vertex might
get a special probability.
It might be
customized, as opposed
to being equally likely with
all of the other edges leading
a vertex.
In fact, I think they
decided that there should
be a 0.15 probability from
each vertex of jumping
at random to the super-node.
OK.
Let's just illustrate
this with an example.
This is a random walk graph that
we've seen before modeling coin
flipping.
And when I add the
super-node, there's
this one new vertex
super, and there's
an edge from the super
vertex to every other one
of the vertices in the graph.
And from each
vertex in the graph,
there is an edge going back.
I've illustrated that
with two-way arrows.
So this is really an
arrow with two arrowheads.
It represents an arrow
in each direction.
Now in the original
paper, actually, Page
didn't talk about
a super vertex.
Instead, he talked about
each vertex randomly jumping
to another vertex.
But that would just get the
whole state diagram completely
clogged up with
edges, so it's more
economical to have everybody
jump to the super vertex
and the super vertex
jump back to everybody.
And that saves a
significant number of edges.
So PageRank, then, is
obtained by computing
a stationary distribution
for the worldwide web.
So s bar is a vector
of length trillions
that the coordinates are
indexed by the web pages.
And we want to calculate
the stable distribution.
And then we'll simply define
the page rank of a page
is its probability
of being there
in the stationary
distribution, the v
component of the stable--
stationary distribution, s.
And of course,
we'll rank v above s
when the probability
of being in v
is higher than the
probability of being in w.
By the way, I don't
have the latest figures,
but there were-- I guess
I've heard people who've
worked for Google say, and in
some of the Wikipedia articles,
that it takes a few
weeks for the crawlers
to create a new map of the
web, to create the new graph.
And then it takes
some number of hours,
I think under days, to calculate
the stationary distribution
on the graph, doing a lot
of parallel computation.
So a useful feature about using
the stationary distribution
is that ways to hack the
links in the worldwide web
to make a page look
important are-- will not work
very well against PageRank.
So for example, one way
to look more important
is to create a lot
of nodes pointing
to yourself, fake nodes.
But that's not going to matter,
because the fake nodes are not
going to have much
weight since they're fake
and nobody's pointing to them.
So even though a large number
of fake nodes point to you,
their cumulative weight is low,
and they're not adding a lot
to your own probability.
Likewise, you could try taking
links to important pages
and try to make yourself
look important that way,
but PageRank won't
make you look important
at all if none of
those important nodes
are pointing back.
So both of these
simple-minded ways
to try to look important
by manipulating links
won't improve your page rank.
The super-node is
playing a technical role
in making sure that the
stationary distribution exists.
So it guarantees that there's a
unique stationary distribution,
s bar.
By the way, I sometimes
use the word stable
and sometimes stationary.
They're kind of
synonyms, although I
think officially we
should stick to the word
stationary distribution.
As I've mentioned before, when
a digraph is strongly connected,
that is a sufficient
condition for there
to be a unique
stable distribution.
That's actually proved in one
of the exercises in the text
at the end of the chapter.
The super-node
mechanism also ensures
something even stronger, that
every initial distribution
p converges to the
stationary distribution,
to that unique
stationary distribution.
Stated precisely
mathematically, if you start off
at an arbitrary distribution
of probabilities
of being in different
states, p, and you
look at what happens to p
after t steps-- remember,
that you get by multiplying the
vector p by the matrix M raised
to the power t-- and you take
the limit as t approaches
infinity, that is to
say, what distribution
do you approach as you
do more and more updates.
And it turns out that
that limit exists,
and it is that
stationary distribution.
So it doesn't matter
where you start,
you're going to wind up stable.
And as a matter of fact,
the convergence is rapid.
What that means is
that you can actually
calculate the stable
distribution reasonably
quickly, because you don't
need a very large t in order
to arrive at a very
good approximation
to the stable distribution.
Now the actual Google
rank and ranking
is more complicated
than just PageRank.
PageRank was the original idea
that got a lot of attention.
And in fact, the latest
information from Google
is that they think it
gets overattention today
in the modern world by too many
commentators and people trying
to simulate ranking.
So the actual rank rules are
a closely-held trade secret
for Google-- by Google.
They use text, they use
location, they use payments,
because advertisers can
pay to have their search
results listed more prominently,
and lots of other criteria
that have evolved over 15 years.
And they continue to evolve.
As people find ways to
manipulate the ranking,
Google revises its ranking
criteria and algorithms.
But nevertheless,
PageRank continues
to play a significant
role in the whole story.